today we woke up to breaking news Obama
isn't woke at all this idea of purity
and your never compromised and your
always political evoke and all that
stuff
yeah you should get over that quickly
the world the world is messy there are
ambiguities people who do really good
stuff and have flaws like if I tweet our
hashtag about how you didn't do
something right or use the word wrong
verb or then I can sit back and feel
pretty good about myself because man you
see how woke I was I called you out you
know that's not that's not activism
that's not bringing about change
so wait you're telling me that ruining
people because they're not as
politically pure as you are is wrong
you mean you Barack Hussein Obama agrees
with everything that Dave Chappelle
Dennis Prager Adam Carolla Dave Rubin
Joe Rogan Reason magazine the G G show
National Review in every sensible
talking head and FoxNews have been
saying all along who ready
how is Don Lemon taking this is Chris
Cuomo conscious what's the New York
Times editorial board gonna do I hope
BuzzFeed Vox Jezebel and Media Matters
have taken all their meds
yeah so it's good to hear this guy
bashed left is to cancel culture but I
wish he'd done it when it mattered when
he was president think of how many
uncancelled people might still have jobs
anti-shah would have stayed in its
basement sniffing its own toes but maybe
it's not his fault
he's a little tardy my theory he didn't
realize how bad it was until his kids
came home from college and said holy
crap dad avocados are tools of the
patriarchy that's what he said damn this
bleep is getting out of hand
when you're the greatest Democrat alive
and your kids might end up joining the
Young Republicans you got to do
something you might want to criticize it
the way Obama did they say you never
grow up until your kids come home from
college which is why I'll never grow up
but the problem with woke culture the
moment you criticize it you're now the
enemy so will this red pilled
Obama be cancelled who knows but I give
him a year before he's listening to rush
in his maggots